[Music]
or coke you ready if you'd like [__]
school check out how the proper [__]
bed you're following oh I would go to me
[__] playground oh [__]
they're back me and my [__] if we go
confront them it's a Monday night you
tuned up on the right night are you
[__] kidding me
young dating hang on right now we know
we walk on they won't even realize when
Harry Potter came out and there were 18
[__] you and Harry Potter business I
responded to suck my dick I don't work
another that [__] here we go another
fun-filled Monday night I hope you got
your lungs are ready his leaves off choo
choo we got big Kansas we are little
canisters we got big canvases we got
little canisters we got mediocre
canisters we got canisters of all sizes
all shapes and all noises they're all
the same color look at yeah that's right
nice-looking let's do something
different today we're all going to show
lead wanna podcast well I'll find it for
you you did beautiful I just didn't you
just we always do I always doing that
you can alright I loved one is wheezing
all time that's perfect I could the
portunity that means that we was working
it's when it's not [__] it's when
it's not [__] wheezing wheezing that
the way they work let's do this [__] do
this [__] oh my god bagel lyrically
right there get that top down get that
good THC burn like that there you go
baby girl you look like first low death
there you go keep it up all the way one
quick one there you go all the way let
that go there you go you [__] animal
of death there you go little [__] you
get your [__] see that see you survive
you ready for another one
we're sharing with one [__] supersets
the crippled fans that's it ready
because right now no no they are no my
quicker than some answers a Super Saiyan
elation like a striking clock ooh and we
make school with all the mummy the back
of the club sipping moet is where you
find me today that stay than ever it is
that's the one you've been waiting for
this most people live a whole lifetime
- you're not doing that and seeing that
you're not taking it go go all the way
one quick one there you go like a
soldier debt-ceiling [__] you're not
doing it Mikey I know don't worry I
don't know today we'll get it right
today
I'm coming down you're not trying your
best your hesitation tells you that's
the whole [__] thing with you whole
thing will we do what do you mean
digging around this [__] we know we
gotta get extra out of this mess I get a
couple good night in an extra week with
you
- inside Jenny - every night delivery
- every night that's at the bottom
number because I
oh [__]
it's Monday night [__] the
luckiest night a week why cuz your
uncle's here uncle Joey and full of fat
[__] and we got all the right tools
tonight we got the chocolate bar look at
the size this purple [__] thing look
at the size of this [__] thing
and this is the backup you cannot go
wrong when you're here with uncle Joey
and it's trusted boom ball of death Lee
sciatica and now it's just great
compensate for a few cuz in a few we
gonna do what we came to do
ain't that right boo crew you know don't
let some alright ain't nothing left from
Long Island I said hit that muley
[__] it's a beautiful night to be
alive
inside him but it don't matter in my and
it feels stupendous tremendous dream
[__] the dollar and the dream what
smoking light up the most all the
brother knows what the [__] this is it
[__] leaves over there on the
mission with a sad face on he looks like
a look at it sucking a dick for the
first time he's over there eat those
[__] stars and you'll need one thing
you you shave all the time like I'm
doing here put it away put it away I
gave you son won't be lying [__] by the
way is that in numbers you don't like
quality similar we don't know I'm the
original Jew I know more numbers in hate
position Jews know a lot of numbers I
know a lot more numbers
does I know how to mix those numbers
around you know I'm saying that's what I
used to call me Joey numbers I can make
you disappear and pop up somewhere else
like the [__] accountant the other
thing very bad [__] they better do a
sequel of that Oh Big E small Junior
MAFIA representing baby baby Oh what we
got here is [__] debt which is you
are denied we like fly out like you know
man's always the 4th of July at all
Joey's up here you go buddy and oh [__]
oh [__] oh [__] you want your life to
change put this truck at Alamo this
little black kid from [__] East New
York dropping it like a bad [__]
hit what I need under that suit upon you
when God come to be [__] around it
[Music]
that's the one right there
don't go away don't go away till they
kill that if you kill that meal there
you go
hold on hold on you let some smoke on
you know hold on there you go that's the
one all the way game blowing the
saxophone
you [__] it up maybe [__] us I'm
saying the training he took the weekend
dog he went and kicked around again in
which the seed [__] he gets [__] soft
on the weak
go to see folks in fact not really
oh [__] oh [__] here we go plug Levi was
he objected walking around you be more
than God incarnate
oh [__] oh [__] what's up dr. B you're
looking good bro you on it's nothing you
got some good update just the protein
that's good that son and you could try
and see how it works for your lungs and
you can recommend it that's how this one
sex for me it has the mushrooms
you order some mushrooms I give you more
see how you like it
it [__] [__] me up the Russians me
anyways I can't think the truth I think
I have one in the control isn't in the
very now I draw new horizon Thomas
Collins that's a bad blood
- chocolate [__] they go but is
that Farley stuck up in the game what
won't be luckily you know simply there
to give enough reasonable sake [__]
around the bundle malicious it's only
[__] oh yeah it's true laughs it's
not even funny
my biggest partly cuz bondage this is
[Music]
how it is hell [__] you is you're taking
an apple in your mouth and you suck a
little bit above your mouth
and it swallow left well it just goes
under has become a smell romantic
walking around pulling the old implement
[Music]
you don't have a nice and more lately I
continue to any probably needs a lot of
[__] things heat or is me yes leave
ACL MCL so he won't be rubber guard
nobody for a [__] long time what are
you going to do
there's what happens when you try to be
a master jiu jitsu when you're in
jiu-jitsu amendment to become a master
hunter [__] bring a few techniques
that's how you become a master but
anyway talk is cheap [__] I become a
master the bunk it let me show you how
it's done in here dr. bliss really
sucking his dick
really he's okay this guy Scott old [__]
around that's a little missus chicken
boy good I love my cup really where you
work let me do a biggie smalls killer
the LOC a holy [__] anyway we're back
[__] more bandits more pop stars who
said stars leap when I show up at the
chocolate because we got things to do
people to see this can't be taken to why
we see the little chocolate ball break
it in half and let's go
what's with the key what's with the king
tonight give me the [__] did you see
how your uncle opens yeah well if you
have something I got nothing
I'm everyone acid in it and like your
cheeks or something I got nothing the
acid isn't a [__] thing that you say
it is that's where there's a sitting
right there staring into forever taking
your cheese from the chip now make a
chipmunk right away with it listen while
he's stalling it's time for another
banda what do you think when people
stall i do but you want to start i go
bong it I don't give a [__] stall all
you want eat that chocolate cut sick
send help as people in Africa right now
looking for a piece of THC chocolate
walking in the mud
[__] bees bite them in the back like
ten black dudes right now going I wish I
had a [__] moon bar and you're over
here complaining complaining meanwhile
we got weed from the [__] 1ig bananas
look at this one this is tremendous this
is a [__] hybrid that'll knock your
ID ball on the end
in fact you're supposed to put tape over
the eyes before you smoke this there you
go there you go there you go go now
we're getting the parties Hey and then
the party till somebody pukes you don't
meet those I'm old school getting a
party to our table breaks or somebody
pukes in the Cuban community when you
break something at a party the first
thing you got to say is oil Roper look
at ty Powell [__] that means break it
it's already paid for
who gives a [__] that's a real party
right there
look at League eating that chocolate
like a [__] soldier at death he's
eating like a piece of fish on his
[__] Bar Mitzvah
you know the 20 you got to eat the fish
constant hell it'd kill for fish right
after what you got to do what right here
that's the doctor police bomb gate
that's what we call those deep ones
those are deep long bonnet when they
come from the civility boy to come
poetical or I said it Filipina your body
are you gonna be shaken from it like
that you you you I can make something to
think up yes behind you eat that
chocolate your filthy Ambria we're doing
bong hits hit Monday if you're they can
go away go do your homework [__]
you have to be the college two years and
you over here watching uncle Joey doing
bunga's go through some with your life
your [__] join the service go shoot Isis
do something but don't just [__] sit
there watching this old [__] bum
doing bondage with his trusted assistant
Cato young saying
younger mommy mommy he's over there
[__] eat you up and stuttering
spitting drooling he's getting ready for
another bucket though he's stretching
those lungs now we got some [__]
tremendous Disney for you from the other
day you like the Disney Dream huh I'm
gonna DreamWorks this will make it this
will put you in a [__] dream that
suck what's this this is the gazonga bug
from the Disney here you go you finish
it - chocolate almost one little piece
right when you finished it and we'll
give you a bunk until that time I've to
do another bump like I said you want to
stall I do a bar you want to bond that
to me
all right we have to sandwich - can you
think about me I think Nikki's nostrils
are flaring
oh yeah Union this is the salmon that's
actually scary looking
I still real data right there
[Laughter]
that's some Cleveland right there that's
a real [__] pier in that drop of lead
when you giggle about I'm a good to use
the tongue I use the chocolate around
see you make the children a late start
your assistant all right so you just
check in with you just to make sure you
watch it watch it
oh boy yeah what's a real Aussie by the
end
we still have stars beat we still got
two episodes it's a double well I got
two more piece of chocolate
and we go everyone deep deep deep
tonight if you haven't seen deep
humility
[Music]
I'm back si had to change the music no
worries uncle Joey's here never fear you
understand me
you replaced the chocolate yeah yeah
yeah all right let's do this
you got made Izzy you help me wipe agree
I'm gonna hit those bongs like I own the
factory his name oh [__] oh [__] oh [__]
here we go
[Music]
ready again
they animated my jacket off about 2:30
[Music]
you
literature three things
[Music]
yeah
keep it right there I'm gonna win
Hey
listen
Oh Chuck thought you might like to go to
the show oh [__] and we go [__]
it's time to see the devil if you
haven't seen the devil it's that [__]
time youtube.com slash lead youtube.com
slash c / show it is that's the place to
be
give me ten minutes to get this thing
won't dump in do a few more bong
Rooney's and we'll get this party
started
understand hopefully come back I got to
do it no Lee like me right now
[Music]
least one application of difference
let see we cannot see between us hope it
be edible the chocolate we got a nurse
coming in for the fifth under episode
everyone that will clean heroin coming
in from the [__] Gulf Coast
oh [__] there you go just when you
thought it would take rape another part
of you
Wow you work with me some happy little
podcast do the dirt another is the
[__] hour and a half guys to me baby
[Music]
the skies are all blue so [__] out
man
I can't even shut this off out of
respect right
[Music]
I still ponder this [__] that that's
still too wet we gotta take it back to
the old school [__] there we go
[__] ding ding ding ding are you
[__] kidding me
the finised I got a scintilla skate on
the thin ice they dropped it to me in
I'm telling these [__] in 2017 if
you're not skating on thin ice on a
daily suit yourself right now just go
[__] tonight top gear that means you're
walking you're pushing that envelope
[__] I'm saying
dr. policeman goes into job that's the
belief that [__] it I'm going to
teach people how to [__] breathe this
[__]
anybody can even say anybody get a
[__] job you gonna walk on thin ice
like the [__] man said
[Music]
ah youtube.com slash Zowie youtube.com
slash Joey Diaz that's a place to be
don't forget Thursday night working out
with uncle Joey 8:30 the Icehouse $10
you're in you're out we crack a couple
jokes you're on your merry [__] way
the end of the month I'm at the board
gala in New Jersey July 29th and I'm in
Vegas I'm in [__] st. Louis here we
go here we go
you got to remember guys this is the
fourth or fifth time in a row on a five
mile run these guys went on this was the
[__] masterpiece right here okay it
was like [__] Dark Side of the Moon
which sold more arms than anything
animals
wish you were here and there was one
other one Unga Munga something like that
they put all five rules on the road with
this being the [__] masterpiece they
never recovered from this they're doing
their own tours in fact Roger Waters in
town tomorrow night for Reese your Idol
invited me come on
so I was going to try to have Mauritian
on Bravo on in July been with Rudy but
Rudy's in talking with the guess who so
it's just a ratio mate and Dino read
July 5th
I'm trying are suckers and I said
youtube.com slash D slash Joey Diaz
remember for every [__] trouble
hummus you buy I just gets a dollar so
the more Amish you eat the more powerful
a [__] get did you see the review
today yes you did
people read hummus get [__] ask assets
on Twitter today right load y'all wasn't
kidding anyway keepin that [__]
hummus don't do it don't do it
[__]
don't do it get nachos Mexicans ain't
bother nobody
I love you guys youtube.com slash z /
Joey Diaz the church what's happenin now
stay back